wir stürzen uns dann mal gleich rein in
unsere zuschauer fälle
wir sind verbunden mit mario reimer erst
bauchredner moderator und kleinkünstler
wir haben die sendung schon sehr sehr
oft über die großen künstler gesprochen
jetzt haben sie sich an uns gewandt wo
drückt bei ihnen der schuh wäre schule
drückt bei uns viele künstler ich bin
nämlich der einzige dem es jetzt drückt
sind ja ganz ganz viele sind zauberer
musiker des shops
veranstaltungstechniker die allem
natürlich in not sind und ich
telefoniere natürlich auch mit dem
kollegen die kollegen da und ich wir
haben auch alle sagt merckx in ungarn
keine auftritte und auch keine
perspektive also keine planbare
perspektive wie das ganze dann
weitergehen soll die leute angst zu
feiern
wir haben versuche gestartet so
testballons mit befreundeten gastronom
zum beispiel haben wir acht termine
angesetzt nach hygiene standards
alle termine wurden abgesagt weil die
weil natürlich denn der gast hat angst
ich verstehe das auch und wir haben es
ja mit der schwerwiegenden krankheit zu
tun
nur ich konnte 20 jahre zum beispiel
meine familie damit wunderbar ernähren
mit meiner mit meiner kunst und kann es
auch heute auf morgen nicht mehr weil
ich mir ein berufsverbot auferlegt wurde
und jetzt ist der punkt zu angekommen
die grundsicherung ist alles gut und
schön es ist aber glaube ich nicht das
richtige instrument um unsere zielgruppe
unsere berufsgruppe aufzufangen und
wieder ich habe frau kind und wir haben
haus und es ist jetzt schon mal also
mittlerweile so weit dass man sagen kann
es geht alles den bach runter und das
dass das so kann es nicht sein dass wir
von der politik leider gottes irgendwie
gar kein oder wenig angehört werden
herein wir lassen uns das noch mal
genauer besprechen
tatsächlich seit märz haben sie keine
auftritte sie mussten wahrscheinlich
auch viele auftritte ja canceln und das
geld natürlich dann auch zurückzahlen
wovon leben sie jetzt ja ich bekomme
aktuell die grundsicherung natürlich
hinten und vorne nicht reicht um seinen
lebensstandard zu halten die man
natürlich vorher gehabt hat weil die
auftragslage war googles normalerweise
es ist es das ganze jahr gut durch
gebucht jetzt kommen die weihnachtsfeier
normalerweise da steht nicht eine
einzige feier an einen anschluss kommt
immer meister karneval
er wird reihenweise abgesagt und die
wenigen veranstaltungen die wir haben
die werden in gründen ja aufs nächste
jahr verlegt dh wir ruhigen am umsatz
kann ich wieder rein wir machen dieses
jahr in cologne bisschen von dem berg
oder gut was wir dieses jahr nicht
wir haben auch sehr oft wirklich richtig
bekannte künstler bei uns in der sendung
gehabt die haben das auch angesprochen
fühlen sie sich so ein bisschen
vergessen weil alle immer nur schauen
wie geht es mit den großen wichtigen
prominenten weiter aber keiner schaut
auf sie
na ja die große schon schreien so muss
man es ja leider gottes sagen wenn die
großen künstler schon schreien die auch
schon lange im geschäft sind
wie soll es dann für uns denn angst
verstecken kleinkünstler sein also ich
spreche mit kollegen die die wein zum
teil weil einem telefon und wie gesagt
die grundsicherung ist sicherlich ein
instrument das uns sicherlich auch erst
mal hilft aber wir haben wir trotzdem
die große lücke und diese finanzielle
lücke die muss ja irgendwo geschlossen
daran und wir als solo selbständige im
künstlerischen bereich haben wir bereits
keine großen betriebskosten das heißt
sie überbrückungshilfe ist ja ein
tropfen auf dem heißen stein für das
wenige was wir meist an betriebskosten
haben und das schlimme ist wir kommen ja
noch nicht mal daran weil die
steuerberater oder steuerberater wenn ja
gar nicht hinterher kommen die anträge
zu bearbeiten
also jetzt meine steuerberaterin sagt
sie kommt gar nicht hinterher weil die
kombi zum alltagsgeschäft weil weil
alles zu viel wird er wie müssen sich
denn jetzt einschränken
uns fehlen jeden monat mindestens 50
prozent der finanziellen kosten die wir
haben glaube ich also es gibt in italien
für mich es gibt ein teil für meinen
sohn für meine frau gibt es einen
kleinen teil obwohl geht ist auch ein
angestelltenverhältnis aber im
teilzeitbereich ja ich bin so weit dass
ich dass ich einen job suchen bin und
mir im ganz normalen normalen job wieder
suchen muss
nur wer stellt mich dann ein ich bin 20
jahre lang selbstständig wenn ich habe
auch abitur ich habe eine kaufmännische
ausbildung ich habe ein betriebswirt
aber bestellt mich denn nach 20 jahren
ein ich krieg da nur absagen
das ist ja das große
problem also selbst da also wenn man
geht ja schon alle wege ich bin optimist
und ich bin wirklich wirklich stark
optimist aber so langsam geht auch mir
der optimismus aus ja das ist
wahrscheinlich wirklich sehr sehr schwer
also ihr fall ging uns auch wirklich zu
herzen ich nehme mal an kemptens dazu
das ist wirklich schon bitter wenn man
da auch keine rücklagen hat und vor
allem auch keine perspektive herein hat
gesagt die weihnachtsfeiern werden jetzt
auch schon abstand immer auch ein ganz
ganz wichtiger punkt in der planung
wie sehen sie den fall also das problem
ist ja dass die bundesregierung und
natürlich auch ja die
verbraucherverbände immer sagen es gibt
ja die ticket lösung damit sind die
verbraucher schon sehr ja sehr belastet
das ist ja die ticket lösen die
gutscheinlösung die eben davon ausgeht
wenn jemand ein ticket gekauft hat für
eine veranstaltung dann bekommt er im
moment ja kein bargeld zurück sondern
nur einen gutschein
das hilft aber und das ist das problem
dabei nur den veranstaltern und nicht
den künstlern weil dieser
zahlungsaufschub dieser rückzahlungs
aufschub nicht bei den künstlern ankommt
sondern bei den veranstaltern bleibt
denn die künstler müssten ja eigentlich
sagen ich habe ausfallen habe ich habe
ja verträge in die meisten künstler
haben ja für das ganze jahr verträge
gehabt und die verträge sind reihenweise
einfach storniert worden und die
künstler bekommen ihr geld nicht denn
eigentlich hätten die künstler ja auch
noch einen anspruch auf zumindest einen
teil entschädigung so was wie ein
ausfallhonorar und da sehe ich
eigentlich das problem dass die ticket
lösung diese gutscheinlösung gut ist für
die veranstalter aber die veranstalter
müssten eigentlich zumindest einen teil
auch an die künstler weitergeben und ich
glaube da ist das problem
herr einer haben sie denn tatsächlich
auch ausfallhonorar gefordert von ihren
kunden
ja man möchte ja keine kunden verlieren
das ist immer das große problem das war
ja auch schon mal ein thema in ihrer
sendung
man möchte irgendwo keinen kunden
verlieren und somit hat man eigentlich
alles was jetzt gewesen wäre aufs
nächste jahr auf 2.021 verschoben aber
es den termin den man 2021 dem kunden
der termin dieses jahr gewesen wäre den
kann ich nicht doppelt vergeben also
dass der islam also das heißt ich habe
irgendwann im nächsten jahr
fange ich dass da bei weitem nicht
wieder auf
wir geben ihnen jetzt 30 sekunden zeit
sie können einen appell an die politik
richten oder auch vielleicht ein mutmach
appell an ihre kollegen haben sie 30
sekunden vor uns ich habe auch länger
hallo ja gerne liebe politik es wäre
schön wenn unsere branche die ja die
sechs größte branche wirtschaftsbranche
in deutschland ist mit 130 milliarden
umsatz wo ja viele viele berufsgruppen
dazu gehören wenn die auch erhört wird
am 19 september ist ja auch eine demo in
berlin
und ich denke wir müssen die
grundsicherung ist nicht das was uns auf
hängt denn es gibt viele existenzen
kaputt ist in über zwei millionen
beschäftigt in dem bereich und ich denke
es ist jetzt an der zeit in einem land
der dichter und denker auch diesen
künstlern und ist dazu gehört nicht nur
klassik jazz oder die die oper sondern
auch die leichte unterhaltung das von
uns ja auch ist ja das merkt man sie
sind moderator kennt sich im showbiz aus
wir wünschen ihnen dass es irgendwann
wieder bergauf geht also das klingt
jetzt nicht so sie sind trotzdem
fröhlich das freut uns sie sind option
ist
ich hoffe dass sie so bleiben und dass
dann irgendwann mal wieder losgeht
vielen dank dass sie in der sendung
waren mario kreimer hallo